alors marie justement marie vous êtes la
reine de l'incrusté puis et la semaine
dernière paris s'est arrêtée de livres à
cause de la grève des transports en
commun vous le savez pour ceux qui
habitent paris voilà c'était la folie et
marie s'est infiltrée auprès des
parisiens galèrent à cause de la ratp en
galère en colère aweys et j'étais venir
ils envoient les étés un brick
c'est marie vie d'alicia nul à la caméra
magnéto c'est à toi serge il a pu le
faire
[Musique]
pourquoi pas
walou par contre si vous voulez moi j'ai
été employé pour s'avancer
d'accord vous pouvez me dire tout ce que
vous voulez pendant une minute sur les
ratés fait je représente la ratp j'ai
fait abstraction de ce joli visage des
gens classés par simon a laissé des
séquelles que je fais moi monsieur je
suis désolé je ne peux pas les géants
faire virer j'étais déjà à votre
employeur et de vos cours au sénat c'est
passionnant pour joe cole dans le
détroit
l'oratoire à long tunnel
non
[Musique]
ceci est un message de la ratp
soyez heureux en ce jour de grève n'est
la journée la joie alors la glace et on
fait quoi il est musulman dans cette
voiture tout leur saoul alors je vois
pas où faire du mal
[Musique]
ok avec vous pas toujours tout frais ça
je prends ma personnalité
apprenant dimanche
la grève des transports c'est la saint
hubert club pour les ibères alors on
s'en met plein les couilles aujourd'hui
une majoration à coire 70 bonne fête
[Musique]
moi ce que j'ai préféré c'est quand tu
tu as cru sur les trottoirs c'est une
ruse d'armé entre les deux séries dan
dah et marie-soleil les avez vous êtes
en ra sera totale ça se passe bien la
personne qui s'énerve s'énerve faut
courir vite en bas ça il ya déjà eu des
débordements des banques et quelques
débordements on a eu quelques mots
qu'est le plaquage au sol quelques
police appelée ben oui mais oui bien sûr
mais souvent je pense à toi
ouais parce que je pense que tu es
souvent allé aux passes oui eh ben moi
pareil ici s'il y est allé et ça se
passe pas bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci organisé pour les prochains mois
tu pourras payer caution ce genre de
chose ou pas ou allez vas y aura pas de
prochain
[Applaudissements]